[Music]
the negotiation can be over before it
even gets started let's pretend I'm an
entrepreneur raising capital from three
different funds operating under three
different cultural norms Camille thanks
so much for your time today in Shanghai
in China in Japan it's customary to make
a two-handed business card exchange
Frank really appreciate the time today
i'ma but in India it's customary to make
a right handed only exchange and you
just have your university or College
calmly slave in the cart as education so
highly regarded Ellen thanks so much for
your time today in San Francisco instead
of giving you a business card I decided
to conserve paper and I'll be texting
you my contact information for that
right well this is a slight exaggeration
many firms in the u.s. are shifting away
from the traditional business card
exchange practice nonetheless at this
point in the meeting a small blender can
have a negative ripple effect throughout
the rest of the negotiation grace Deepa
Felix and I are going to explore the
strategies and cross-cultural
negotiations while we're all pretty
familiar with the concepts of IQ and EQ
what about CQ cultural intelligence CQ
could be understanding once addressed
more formally for presentation and when
to wear a hoodie everything comes is so
much more than that
pre negotiation formalities such as
handshakes exchange of business cards
and simple greetings can be culturally
independent and the most compelling
argument in negotiation may become null
and void if you black the awareness
upfront the keys to navigating these
negotiations are pretty consistent
across cultures a strong argument a
willingness to capitulate on certain
aspects and desire to reach a conclusion
and while finding an outcome and
cultural differences are not mutually
exclusive having the awareness and
preparedness will ultimately put you in
a better position to
see there also exists a there versus
here fallacy people wrongfully assume I
have no plans of raising money or doing
business in Russia any time soon but
what happens when in Russia investor
comes to you what happens when
there-there comes here cultural context
is independent of geography and it's
very important to be aware of that our
goal today is to provide you with three
basic tactics and strategies that will
give you the continents help navigate
through these cross-cultural
negotiations I'm now going to pass off
the deeper go talk about the nuances of
disagreement thank you my disagreement
is inevitable in any negotiation let's
take a quick peek a short video sorry
pardon reduce yes
hello so Wiarton you wish you 24 million
new shares of stock you were told that
if new investors come upon your shares
diluted how much were it is lots of
emotion right does that happen to any of
us and what makes this more complicated
in a cross cultural context is the fact
that the weak disagreements are
expressed very significantly from one
culture to another researchers think
that there are two essential
characteristics of how disagreement or
expressed one is how confrontation is
expressed and the second is how
emotional for example if you're in a de
Cassation
with a Russian counterpart this is
strong likelihood that he or she will
disagree but pretty much every single
thing you see the construct their
perspective that is an open invitation
to have an animated and lively
discussion on the other hand if you're
in a negotiation symmetrical counterpart
you may want to solve them the
disagreement so that you don't run the
risk of completely shutting down the
conversation so too many plans core
organizing a trip to Mohawk our timing
and your negotiating the terms with the
engineering you may want to approach it
along the lines of
I'm not sure I quite understand it but
could you explain a little bit more
researchers on the street that
negotiators have an assumption which is
a policy that emotional expressiveness
goes hand-in-hand with confrontation and
that's not always the case
your German counterparts may be very
open to confrontation but only so long
as it expressed calmly and factually on
the other hand your alien counterpart
may be polite and soft when it comes to
confrontation but will wear their
emotions on their sleeve so now that
were aware of these different cultural
nuances and context how can we be
prepared for a cross-cultural
negotiation linguistic experts say that
the key is to analyze verbal cues and
they specifically highlight - - - what
they call up craters and down readers a
grievers are words like absolutely
completely that has been strengthened
the disagreement
whereas boundaries are words like maybe
just a little bit that helped to soften
the disagreement the key really is to
make sure that you analyze and
understand these verbal cues within
their cultural context so that you're
able to adapt your reaction and your
response accordingly that will help you
be more successful and more active in
establishing rather in connection with
verticals and with that I'm going to
hand over to place who's going to walk
us through the invocation of the words
yes or no in the cross country do you
want to watch another video yeah No
am i right and thinking there is nobody
else in this house
no then there is someone else in this
house no sorry I said no meaning yes no
meaning yes in the United Kingdom where
I grew up
yes means yes and no means no so this is
where things get confusing for me in
some countries such as Egypt
yes actually means no or maybe or
think about it or I really want to do
what you want but it's absolutely not
possible and I hope you can tell that by
my body language a verbal yes might be
seen as more polite or pleasing and
there's no expectations that yes is
binding in parallel there are some
cultures and where no no might actually
mean yes or let's discuss it further
wait wait let's say you're doing a
negotiation with a French person let's
say Claire and she responds to a
question with no no no no no she might
actually mean yes she just wants it to
be bit a bit further so is yes means no
and no means yes don't ask yes or no
questions
instead of saying can you do this for me
say by when will you be able to do this
for me and if you just have to ask that
yes or no question make sure to analyze
tone and body language for example yes
it's very different than yes now that
we've discussed the difficulties of yes
and no question I'm going to hand it
over to Felix
who's going to discuss problems with
putting things in writing thank you
great people and great immerse you into
the calendar so for a negotiation has in
terms of oral communication or whatever
what we put in writing and whether we
have to put it into writing you know I
don't do contractions but what you do
have is my word and it's stronger than
oak
so in the countries on the left-hand
side of the screen especially in Africa
in Asia a word is stronger than oak but
in other countries the one you have on
the right hand side of hand side of the
screen we like the good things into
drive so let's take the US for instance
guides here in the US you like clarity
and repetition as a way to make sure
that the other party understands what
you were negotiating about so to us if
you go back to what Amara I'm sure you
would be doing that and you need the
procurement division at your family
business don't be surprised when you
negotiate with your American suppliers
and they send you an email with a list
of things you have a bid on and even ask
you to reply back to them by saying yes
I agree with that they do that and you
guys do that and we do it in Western
cultures because we want to protect
ourselves against potential
eventualities and because we want to
build trust with a counterpart that we
don't necessarily know as opposed to
that in African countries like Nigeria
for those of you who when I go into
Africa record business people will take
an email or a contract as a sign of
disrespect and also as a sign of lack of
trust they want you to be flexible be
flexible around two things first to take
a contract an order contract as a bread
contract and secondly to take an oral
contract as something that is flexible
and can change over time because they
co-sponsors change so the third piece of
advice review and how we want you to be
prepared is actually to ask your
counterpart to prepare the first strap
of the contract so that they feel more
comfortable with it and remember one
thing in some countries around the world
a contract is not binding at all so by
now you are all the other one over by
you'll get by the country the references
the friends are we have from France from
different countries we want you to
remember four things the first one is
you have to analyze the verbal cues and
adaptive reaction to emotion we're
proceeding from the other from the other
party second thing is a voyage and no
questions asked reset and thirteen is
these are the only party to try the
first track of the
the contract if you have to do so so
that they feel more comfortable with it
but if you want you to remember
something is the 8bs framework be aware
of the differences be prepared for those
differences so that you can be more
successful next time you are negotiating
in a different quarter thank you very
much and now we'll be happy to take any
questions
[Music]